die Leute werden doch tendenziell eher
wieder für 8 Euro bei ihrem Dealer
kaufen wo sie wissen okay da ist müsst
jetzt auch nichts passiert weil es eine
Vertrauensfrage ist und das heißt wenn
ich weiß ich kriege es schnell am Kotti
halt mein Zeug dann ist es ja dann also
dann ist es naiv zu denken dass die
Leute auf einmal alle in Clubs geben
werden
erstmal daran arbeiten dass er ein guter
Punkt man könnte sagen das Zeug am Gotti
bleibt billiger ich kenne den Dealer
schon lange jetzt bleibe ich auch bei
dem der Club interessiert mich nicht ich
glaube das ist nicht so ist das sagen
noch die Experten weil viele werden ja
hören das Zeugnis für unreinigt wenn ich
über den Kotte gehe ich bin dass es ein
oder andere mal und schaue mir die
Dealer dort an die ihrerseits
typischerweise ruinabhängig oder was
auch immer abhängig sind dann würde sich
der ein oder andere denken wenn das
jetzt hier so zu beschaffen ist ohne
dass das also illegal wäre und ohne das
beimengen sind und so weiter da gehe ich
doch nicht mehr zu dem Typen
[Musik]